- [Kim] Hey historians.
Kim from Khan Academy
here with a quick guide to
the 2020 AP U.S. History exam.
I'm gonna go over the details
about the new exam format
and how the scoring system has changed.
Okay, here's what you need to know.
First, the exam is taking place
on Friday, May 15th, 2020.
The time depends on where you live.
So, you'll get all the information
you need on when and how
to sign in from the College Board
if you've registered for the exam.
The overall scoring system
for the exam hasn't changed.
You'll still receive a
score between one and five,
and it's still up to colleges to decide
how many credits they'll
award you based on that score.
The College Board says they're confident
that most colleges will
accept this year's AP scores
just as they would for any other year.
You'll have 45 minutes to take the exam
plus five minutes for uploading
at the end of that period.
You can type the exam if you've
got access to a computer,
or you can write it out longhand on paper
and take pictures of your essay
if you wanna upload it
through your smartphone.
If you need help accessing
technology so you can take
and submit the exam,
reach out to the College
Board as soon as you can.
I'll put a link to the
forum in the description.
So now let's talk about
the format of the exam.
It's a little different.
The whole exam is just going to be
one document-based question, DBQ.
So there won't be any multiple choice
or short answer questions or a long essay.
The good news is that
this year there will be fewer documents
than your standard DBQ.
Five documents instead of seven.
And one of those will be something
other than a text-based source.
So, a political cartoon, a photograph,
map, something like that.
And, the exam will also cover
fewer periods of U.S. history.
Just Periods 3 through 7.
So that goes from 1754,
or the start of the Seven Years' War,
through 1945, the end of World War II.
The exam is going to be open book.
So you can have any books
or notes you want with you.
But you can't copy and paste from sources
or collaborate with other students.
So, don't text your friends
the minute you get the prompt.
The College Board has said
they're gonna crack down
very hard on cheating,
and they'll use plagiarism software
to detect similar essays.
All right, now let's talk about
how this DBQ will be scored.
It's a little different
from previous DBQs,
since there are fewer documents
and less time overall.
You'll be able to earn up to
10 points instead of seven.
So let's go through the points
you can earn one by one.
First, there are the thesis
and contextualization points.
These are the same as they
have been in past exams.
You get one point for including
a historically defensible claim
that gives a line of reasoning in either
the introduction or the conclusion.
This means you've gotta
answer the question prompt
with an argument that's factual,
and you need to say why
you think it's true.
Contextualization gives a broader sense of
what was happening in the time period
in a way that's relevant to your thesis.
So, if the question is about
industrialization in the Gilded Age,
you wanna explain the context of
the expansion of factory
work and urbanization,
not something about the impact of
the Dawes Act on indigenous
people in the West.
Just because something's
happening at the same time
doesn't mean that it's
relevant context for
the argument you're making.
Okay, now let's talk
about the evidence points.
This is the area where there are
the most differences from
the usual DBQ scoring.
Here's how you can earn the points.
You get one point for describing
the content of two of the
five documents accurately.
That means not just quoting from them,
but showing your understanding of
what's happening in the document.
And you can earn another point
for using those two documents
to support your argument,
tying them back directly to your thesis.
And you can earn another point
by going above and beyond
by accurately describing four documents
and using those to
support your argument too.
Then there's evidence
beyond the documents.
You can earn up to two more
points by bringing in one
or two more pieces of evidence
to support your thesis,
drawing on your own
knowledge of the material.
Now, it's not just mentioning
some other piece of evidence,
you have to show that you
know what you're talking about
when you use it.
So you can't just say,
"Another example of reform was
"the Temperance Movement."
You need to say something like,
"The Temperance Movement
was another reform movement
"that encouraged Americans
to make a voluntary change
"for the better by
abstaining from alcohol."
The analysis and reasoning points
are also slightly different this year.
So, instead of requiring you
to provide a source analysis
for three of the seven documents,
the College Board is being
considerably more lenient,
and awarding one point for explaining
the relevance of the point
of view, purpose, situation
or audience of one of
the provided documents.
And another point for doing
so for a second document.
Remember that your source
analysis needs to go deeper
than just a surface mention.
Don't just say,
"The Emancipation
Proclamation was written in
"the context of the Civil War."
But something like,
"Lincoln issued the
Emancipation Proclamation after
"the U.S. Army won the Battle of Antietam,
"hoping that the victory
and the new commitment
"to ending slavery would
prevent European powers
"from allying with the Confederacy."
So make sure that you explain
why the extra information
you provide about the source
connects back up to your thesis.
The last point is for demonstrating
a complex understanding of the topic.
This is the same as in the old rubric.
So you get a point for
corroborating, qualifying
or modifying your argument.
In other words, you
show that you understand
that history isn't neat and tidy.
There are exceptions, ways
that historical actors
or movements fell short
of their goals or ideals,
or other sides to consider
when making a statement about the past.
Now, I know all of this
has a lot to take in.
I'm gonna provide a link
to the new rubric in
the description so you can
check it out for yourself.
But in essence, it's just
a shorter form of the DBQ.
So don't sweat the details.
You've got this.